when I'm joined on sky knees by Kylie
Minogue pop star actress and campaigner
master of many talents thank you much
for joining us here on Sky News 26 years
since you first released a single in
1988 still at the top of your game how
have you achieved that ah how have I
done that persistence persistence I love
what I'm doing passionate about it and
actually right now I feel reinvigorated
you know I'm really excited about this
new album and I feel like I'm its new
beginnings for me
talk about the sexualization of the pop
industry a lot of people look at Miley
Cyrus she's been accused of poisoning
young girls as some of the material that
she's produced and her twerking you were
famous for your gold hot pants the 1990s
you didn't face any of that kind of
backlash why is it changed what do you
think has changed I admire people like
like Miley like Rihanna
you know girls that are just the quite
on apologetic about what they're doing
is it too much it depends on on what you
know your personal taste is but she's
definitely a scapegoat for for what
might be happening on the broader in the
broader sense important she just get a
hard time because nobody doubts that
she's talented but she seems to get a
lot of attention yeah the wrong women
don't forget there was there's always
been sex drugs and rock and roll but as
you say the guy seemed to get away with
it there is a need for good role models
for young people in the UK we've got
Prince William Prince Harry I know you
performed with them at the Jubilee do
you think of them as good role models I
love them I absolutely love them and
performing at the Jubilee was literally
as one of the the highlight of my career
it was amazing
I'm baby Prince George and his parents
Prince William and Kate Middleton or the
Duchess of Cambridge's she now is will
be going to Australia your homeland and
New Zealand in April for a three-week
tour do you think the Minogue's would be
turning out to where um maybe maybe I'm
not even sure if I'm there then I'll be
there in spirit I think this young
generation of Royals are just cool
they're dedicated to what they have to
do but generally people love them myself
included
you're honestly used to lots of media
attention cameras everywhere you go how
do you find that ah you know sometimes I
don't mind it to be honest if there is
if they're respectful that's cool
do you find them respectful here in the
UK some of them I don't want to tarnish
them all with the same same brush but
not all of them no definitely not all of
them and um it can sometimes make you
feel like like your house has been
robbed or something it's a weird like
they've taken something from you because
again some of them not all but some are
really
still a really nasty well you can what
say what do you get what they say to you
or the way they approach you not so much
what they say to me but um you know you
can't see where you're going you're
going to fall over they're trying to get
on flattering angles get you getting in
or out of the car and the weird thing is
especially if it's nighttime but
sometimes in the day as well you don't
want to see their faces so you don't
it's just you don't can't even think
where you where you're you want to
project your sometimes your anger your
frustration and I did slightly different
story but I remember years years ago I
was walking home from somewhere walking
down my street alone and two guys leap
out you know hoodies and all of this and
and I didn't know that were
photographers I'm like what what's about
to happen and it was totally fine to
just be leaping kind of harassing me and
I just thought I that's what I don't get
that any young woman maybe it wasn't
that young any woman and walking down
the street surely that's that's not
writing was it feels threatening yes and
to be a long way from home then from
your close family is that one of the
reasons that you you talk recently about
about loneliness about it being one of
your biggest fears me many people be
surprised by that is it because they're
there it could be part of it but I think
it's it's something that's beyond that
it's just it's one of my things that if
I was to become kind of you know
melancholy or I definitely have moments
where I'm even quite morose you know her
my everyone has to do it you have to go
down sometimes and yeah I can I can feel
quite quite lonely even if my family was
around I think my my job and my my
lifestyle is is not something that
everyone can relate to